il y a deux semaines m6 diffusé les
portraits des douze agriculteurs qui
vont participer à la 16e saison de
l'amour est dans le pré
sauf que ces dernières années l'émission
a rencontré quelques polémiques qui dans
certains cas ne donne pas une très bonne
image des agriculteurs comment saison 15
ou eric un candidat pour le moins rustre
avait fait vivement réagir ou encore la
saison d'avant 2019 lorsque fatima une
prétendante affirmé que didier l'avait
trahi en décembre de la même année
charles henry s'en prenait quant à lui à
la production de l'émission on oublie le
montage mensonger à son encontre puis a
fait beaucoup de tort dérapages là
encore en septembre 2020 quand le roi
explique dans l'émission qui souhaite
mettre son sexe dans un buisson
des propos qui ont beaucoup choqué les
internautes et qui n'ont pas redorer le
blason des agriculteurs alors l'amour
est dans le pré l'émission fait elle mal
à l'image des agriculteurs
non non non non non je vais donc prendre
que le oui évidemment qu émission fait
du mal aux agriculteurs à leur image
mais on le dit depuis une forme noire
depuis le départ l'émission l'amour est
dans le pré n'a rien de n'être c'est
pour moi ce qu'il ya de plus déplorable
à la télévision parce que les personnes
qui participent sont des personnes qui
sont sincères qui sont honnêtes mais qui
jamais ne se doute que la chaîne se
jouera 2 et grossir à leurs traits pour
les rendre grotesque pour que les petits
bobos les regarde avec leur folk comme
l'asthme à se [ __ ] de la gueule des
agriculteurs font ça innommable mais la
cgt
s'il était si grotesque les gens ne
seraient pas inscrits dont la
combientième de saison de l'amour est
dans le pré la psy qui sont prêts à
passer entre guillemets 30 mai pour des
condiments qu'il passe à la télé at ele
ferrer mais hier c'est aujourd'hui dans
des vapeurs du véhicule quoi les olas et
c'est même méchant delcassé il est loin
d'être stéréotypes et lorsqu'on trouve
on voit cette agricultrice habillé en
rose qui prend soin de ses vos gants
même temps est très porté sur soi-même
son sabot et sa belle et ce métier ouais
a contrario lorsque vous regardez des jt
ont pas d agréger t on pas des acteurs
soit pour leur suicide soit du fait que
les moissons était mauvaise
ou parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à joindre
les deux bouts adam szalai lois qui sont
valorisés je ne peux pas dire ça mc
c'est pas c'est pas il ya des fois ils
ont des positions irritant jugement il
passe nous parce que les imbéciles
l'émission d'une hantise bien non ils
sont pourtant têtus son pnb s'il veut
c'est bon on va aborder le monde le
monde de paysans kevin battant justement
vous tendez une personne aux mains si je
peux me permettre c'est que justement à
travers cette émission je ne connais
rien du monde de la culture est là
justement ça les humanistes quelque part
ça les rend humain et on commence à
comprendre aussi la dureté de leur
métier de leur milieu au quotidien c'est
un choix de vie leur métier c'est leur
vie c'est leur quotidien mais jamais
parti en vacances ils peuvent jamais
déconnecté c'est leur vie à part entière
dont au contraire je trouve que ça
valorise aussi l'agriculture quelque
part oui oui juste une petite réflexion
c'est vrai que moi je déteste amour est
dans le pré mais pour autant c'est une
émission car elle me permet de montrer
des gens qu'on ne voit pas la télé et ce
que j'aime dans cette émission c'est que
les candidats par exemple ne connaissent
pas les codes de la télé donc je sens
chez eux de la sincérité de
l'authenticité est donc pour moi la
production ne change pas voilà les
agriculteurs y sont commis sont dans la
vie donc sûrement leur image de chômeurs
et puis c'est l'alarmé
c'est de trouver l'amour si quand même
au final ce soir là mais quand même le
but de cette émission et c'est vrai que
honnêtement et on l'a on les met en
lumière ils ont peut-être pas forcément
l'occasion d'avoir aujourd'hui aux fins
d'aider des endroits pour se rencontrer
que c'était quand on vit pas à paris ou
en région parisienne c'est peut-être
plus compliqué avec un tracteur non non
mais la raison alors moi je suis pas
démissionné mais il va être le bilan le
bilan amoureux né hier soir seront
envoyées spéciales y avait un avantage
sur les agriculteurs sur leur détresse
sur leurs difficultés
oui jamais dire sur les braises avec ses
soeurs du rhin on est quand même assez
loin de la lampre et on a notamment un
extrait avec cette pièce d'un
agriculteur qui a vécu une scène digne
d'un film d'aventurés regardé c'était le
12 avril 2020 il est 2h 12 du matin
lorsque léa quitte la bergerie pour
rentrer chez elle après une journée de
travail elle aperçoit alors des voitures
s'éloigner d'un de leurs troupeaux
l'éleveuse comprend tout de suite qu'il
s'agit d'un vol et prend les voitures en
chasse plus tard les gendarmes appelés
par léa engage à leur tour une course
poursuite
un homme est finalement interpellé dans
sa voiture il retrouve trois brebis
terrifier les moutons ont été ligotés
par les pattes et ils ont été chargés
comme des vulgaires boîtes de chaussures
empilés quasiment les unes sur les
autres
elles sont mortes dans les jours qui ont
suivi par le stress pour le coup c'est
vraiment horrible témoin faut vraiment
être alors écrit je veux pas dire le mot
je t'avais aller voter un volet des gens
qui déjà galère les agricultures grave
des gens là ce qu'on a vu hier sans
cette loi fait que la police qui
essayent tant bien que mal de faire des
fautes ne peut rien faire dans ces
comptes ne sont là ça le chef d'escadron
mithouard a procédé à plusieurs
interpellations
à chaque fois les suspects font partie
de la communauté rom
la ville compte une soixantaine de
bidonvilles ou vite une partie de la
communauté rom à plusieurs reprises
les gendarmes y ont trouvé des moutons
stockés dans une décharge les pattes
ligoté et parfois attaché aux caravanes
malgré ces quelques interpellations
les vols continuent le capitaine
mithouard avoue à demi-mot l'impuissance
des forces de l'ordre c'est très
difficile mais on essaie de faire au
maximum
mais la difficulté c'est que le
territoire est vaste donc très facile
pour commettre ce type de vol sans être
détecté par des gens de passage où les
forces de sécurité
ballard m livide faux parce que c'est
regarder les images quoi cci nomades moi
c'est insoutenable avoir c'est que c'est
compliqué j'imagine effectivement les
difficultés des forces de l'ordre mais
je sais pas pourquoi
pendant les gars de pan détention je
sais pas que je je je comprends pas très
bien si tu savais que voilà bon celle
apparemment c'est répétitif c'est
régulier etc et on peut rien faire mais
refaire encore tellement de problèmes
comme ça en france où l'on rit c'est
terrible